Hey Oh Go damn I'm excited today I'm on
to my favorite games this year little
nightmare just came out with a DLC I
think it's this one oh god I hope it's
that one I don't know it came out of
nowhere it's early the DLC is early I
repeat everyone oh such a nice surprise
this is definitely it
what who are you Wow why did your head
look like a meatball you look delicious
how did we end up here oh I'm drowning
oh oh we read that I remember this place
this is where we met the enemy for the
first time oh I'm so cute so in we're on
the boat still then playing as one of
the children this is awesome I'm so glad
we're getting more content of this game
where do I go I forgot I forgot about
Teddy can I go back and get him I forgot
the controls I've got everything come on
okay great jeez is he gonna come and
check on me I best be going then alright
well this way it is there he is oh he's
he chasing the girl from the original
that's funny oh no she died I had this
theory that this guy is a nice guy he
just looks horrible cause he never he
never actually kills you he just
captures you or whatever maybe just one
of those clingy parents you know
actually you know you know what I'll
take it back he's horrible there you go
it's the boat what luckily placed
mattress we've been here as well oh [ __ ]
it's the slug I know what those do I
will not say hi to you today mixer
giant black don't say penis okay cool
we've been there as well this is weird
we're playing behind the scenes ah
little girl down Xie all right we'll tip
tap our way through if I remember how I
grabbed stuff I need
now I need to jump down here okay I see
I complete I don't know which one I grab
with and I know it's just an important
move here we go we're gonna have to run
back aren't we
fine and remember which one I run on
that's sneak you know what Litton sorry
okay
sprint grab flashlights crouch okay
sorry now you don't have to hear me keep
going I don't know the controls mommy
there you go oh god where do I hide it
what a major [ __ ] I thought for sure
that would be covered in the middle I
just assumed that there would be right
let's do that again
what the [ __ ] was that all right here we
go
I don't trust that [ __ ] though I ain't
trusting no [ __ ] that be snitchin
like snitches there we go come back here
girl where you going girl with three bag
I'm going to throw up you burn your
[ __ ] face
come here you want this cube you want to
play Minecraft game it's just like my
real life
come back here lady where'd you go
I love this area so cute
alright I assume we have to go back up
here there's no potato people left
I don't know why I'm doing this
it's figured great job Felix and your
life Jesus Christ okay I can just go
here it's fine it's fine I know what I'm
doing professional gamer here look I
have toilet paper that's right that's
right
thank you everyone toilet paper anyone
need some I got you Pam what is she
doing
oh what a dick that's fine I have toilet
papers yeah an epic man a man Avenue
yeah see I got you fam coming to get you
girl I don't know why I'm coming to get
you but I'm gonna catch up that I was a
joke everyone thank you ten out of ten
all right let's grab this and let's go
down nice and easy where's she going
she's going in there in the hole she's
going in the hole come back here when
it's safe to jump off now I would assume
I'm fine I'm fine
it'd be funny if you started playing at
the inside character or some [ __ ] all of
a sudden it's a lot twist this game is
canon okay I assume we have to go down
there but I also kind of want to check
around okay well let's just go I'm fine
swim swim swim swim swim I don't trust a
I don't trust the water I don't trust
the water I just don't trust the water
get out of the water thank you
what the [ __ ] what do I do here
hell no it's vibrating my controller is
like non-stop vibration alright we got
it we got to pull this which I don't
like even more why is my controller
freaking out
it's like Jake it's my scrotum look at
em vibrating like crazy
what does it happen what is okay we go
did it everyone let's just go through I
don't want to check the background I'll
get the flashlight now we can use it
cool
wish you use would be nice
nice and cozy are you scared now I bet
you're scared I never get scared so it's
okay oh god that's a giant slug thing
all right I would say hi but I gonna go
with by this time thank you
Africa yes the wind great so far there
that [ __ ] jesus [ __ ] christ he
distracted me nearly got me killed boy
crouched yes ah nope coming from the
ceiling not a problem
I saw that one I know I got stuck in the
pipe what the [ __ ]
ah it keeps vibrating I know it stops I
thank God that was super annoying
[ __ ] out I got stuck in this stupid
pipe right there faster in the water
it's almost like they're water creatures
or something Hey look at that
yeah keen oh god what do I do here oh
yeah boy
oh yeah me no it's [ __ ] awesome man
alright so aren't you gonna like there
you go okay whoa
oh god that does not sound nice what ya
did it there that's everyone thank you
so much
Oh God okay the [ __ ] is this okay
hey I don't trust anything what Oh God
swing swing okay great okay swing swing
swing swing
what's happening here
what is this glass
okay I don't know what this DLC is cause
I don't know what it's about I just just
random to the side what's available now
I'm like hell yeah I'm just gonna get it
oh god okay this is very dark give me my
flashlight I don't think I can use a
potato pad
tell me legit he looks like a meatball
and they're right if you're home
IKEA it's my city whoa that was deeper
than I expected I strongly feel like
some sort of yep okay well this is great
this is where we die there's chairs
there's chairs coming to kill me please
for the love of God swim girl you almost
got me mr. chair
not today this meatball lives another
day Bob I said bow instead of bro thank
you uncut footage you know it always
does well doesn't show how cringy I am
in as a human being thank you thank you
everyone I don't know why I did that
right there a giant rectum here
I don't like it am I supposed to go here
now click it no down here maybe I feel
like I would die no I'm fine with that
how about that excellent what is this
alright you come up with me now oh god
that looks that looks very bad I excuse
me ah ah that did the trick
great excellent let's let's go here oh
god they're really [ __ ] fast why did
I run I forgot I could I pressed a I'm
so stupid Jesus okay fine run this time
that would be I would be super super
duper I know why I feel safer on this
thing but really in reality I'm [ __ ]
not
hey look at that if you actually run you
win how about that who would have
thought you should have to run crazy
good I don't trust it
but no I've got it speaking to me come
on black caught up okay great
more water for [ __ ] sake man looks
like we got a lot of climbing to do here
Bruce a lot of climbing for a one-week
fall to make
or punished oh this ship is this who
plays a random toilet there no toilet
paper for you buddy yeah Oh God grab it
there you go video game rules if there's
a switch you got it
the [ __ ] ah [ __ ] alright fine
maybe we need to release the pressure
first if you know what I mean
alright here we go what there you go
Sani huh my bad wow what a tricky puzzle
there yes I got em I got em I got em I
am filling up yeah yeah yeah yeah oh I
get it I get it
we gotta hurry up
whoo swim swim swim swim swim swim swim
swim swim swim swim how do i I died I
died everyone II I died did I not die
what yeah that's how drowning works
everyone in case you weren't aware you
lose any breath of air
you instantly die there you go above my
water where does the trick
stop stop that's enough to which thank
you wow
try not to get it in your mouth buddy
there you go nice nice and smooth I love
playing this game it plays so nicely I
love it
something about it all right new place
let's save this barrel for no reason
no okay okay well I don't what you know
push you out no just look at it right
here okay Wow oh gee can I pull you know
it's definitely something in the water
here you can feel it I literally can't
feel it Mike oh god I see him my
controller is right well what the [ __ ]
it's a giant's wow that's creepy but
don't kill me mr. sea monster get up ah
[ __ ] get up get up
swim leave me alone I hate this get up
get up get up get well
hey guys freaking out oh oh god I'm
sweating for real oh my god
sweating for real I am NOT a [ __ ]
seal cheese okay calm down we can do
this easy the ease the game boom BAM
slam slam Sam and lami damn don't
[ __ ] touch me fill the footbridge
can't touch it
ah [ __ ] you it's going to [ __ ] do I'm
going here for no reason hey you like
alcohol I got you family that got
grabbed it what do you think I saw one
of these before
okay so these are the new collectibles
okay great
it's a bottle post great hey maybe we
can use it as distraction yeah but idiot
idiot
yes
boy that was straight up yes oh it's BS
no didn't I know kids slang shut up
great jump there Felix you gold star
buddy I see you Oh God
Oh [ __ ] you're a real penis don't
[ __ ] touch me man all through the box
now okay I see how it is oh my god this
thing I hate it man was gonna get mad at
me
oh he's not playing the game perfectly
hell yeah if I did it he I'd be over a
long time ago man [ __ ] you can't
[ __ ] touch me swim swim swim get up
ain't that [ __ ] hard [ __ ] [ __ ] a
duck that's right bye bye bye there we
go
can we pull this it's a box everyone I
can climb here I see it now okay
sorry I wasn't paying attention that is
probably your mama your mama everyone
your mama jokes huh for the morning not
too much in it unless it goes down by
itself
alright gosh that will do little dead
copes
that'll do what the [ __ ] oh my god okay
then die why does he need not grab that
what's your [ __ ] problem alright I'm
ready for you don't [ __ ] [ __ ] with me
alright cuz I will swing back swing back
slowly but that was not nearly good
enough oh now you can grab it oh that's
interesting
that's really interesting thanks for
letting me know about that one ah you
want some fish come Sogeti
oh there's more of it but it just keeps
coming looks delish
I'll have something yeah I think like
victimok some some more while I swim
it's way tastier than me look I'm skinny
that I fish it's fat like your mama
bottom absolutely just get up thank you
thank you thank you I do that [ __ ] are
you man got him and got him right am i
right hey you want to shoot you want to
[ __ ] shoot hey I know you want to see
you want you want to shoot hey you got
here err it's a fish [ __ ]
absolutely ranked no recovery now
there's more shoes could do it all day
but you know what I'm not gonna I have
dignity oh god what am i oh ah ah I mean
for that to happen
alright how do I get up there get up
here no that's not what I Oh
hey I could push up evidence evidence
ah Rams dude we got a ball we got a ball
everyone dribble
going left going right going just a
double spin it goes up and it shares
this talk these words at sport stop I
don't want you mr. Cain stop CAD thank
you
alright here we go here we go just aim
at the thing and shoot
okay let's try that again
aim at the basket and shoot [ __ ] ball
yeah hell yeah man oh yeah man what does
that do with it I don't know why I just
did this what the [ __ ] are you telling
me that all I had to do was climb up
here is that no I can yeah Oh what
[ __ ] distracted by a basketball game
Jesus Christ well done
okay here we go it's gonna be epic jump
whoa probably get men I did it man help
you me I can't reach the [ __ ] can all
it's fine who needs them oh I see it wow
that's cool that's actually pretty cool
nope okay here we go
buy that I pop that up can you run in a
straight line please mister meatball
[ __ ] yo meatball yes Oh No
get up get up get a [ __ ] a why am i
saying and [ __ ] man ah chair you're not
even doing it for me man
I get it I need to push the chair mr.
chair is my bit I can't push chair so
[ __ ] it then maybe I can just climb
these handles okay I can nope that's not
what I wanted you to do but you know
live your life the way you want to live
it rule one there's the lever you gotta
pull it
oh wow that's a lot deeper than I
thought that's what she said okay I'll
stop I promise
like you've never made that joke okay
sorry
I know I had a con why Sarab yeah triple
phobia with the funk okay they really
don't want that pot to break clearly so
we're gonna [ __ ] smash the [ __ ] out
of it something living is inside I'm
going to get the rat type in the
comments right now what you guess it is
inside the pot I know it's going to be a
key but what else all right
I'm Dorothy exploring you guys right now
come on tell me push it
bye bye it was a slug
Congrats to everyone that gets the slug
probably no one because I am the
smartest and I'm always right so the rat
is actually the right answer I think if
you mean mr. slug could you get the [ __ ]
out of my way please all right all right
yep
look how he walks by sucking what a
shitty life grab the key yes and then
run excellent
and then no that's not what a yes that's
how you unlock doors Felix all right now
it's time to get that [ __ ] out of here
bye bye bye
Oh youngling doing great there are
deaths by the way really proud of this
playthrough doing really well having
died a single time okay here we go
another area what's up got electrons
that he pressed the button make it stop
but yes that's fly no it's the electric
but now the current doesn't leave the
water so we're safe for staff but it
could be time so let's be careful take
me up please
up and onwards please let me fall really
loves water huh all right let's press
the button again see what happens it's
probably going to go up we have plenty
of [ __ ] temperature [ __ ] I'm dead I'm
alive
yes that was not the way I imagined
things to go but it worked out I mean of
course perfectly calculated there is s
by the way hello bucket you're coming
with me
never mind stay there then use our
potato son of a [ __ ] see if I give a
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] we're back in
the showers oh god that's a sexy [ __ ]
we saw her favorite [ __ ] oh I get it now
I get it why people like what no don't
[ __ ] know stop you need to stop
you're ugly all right you need to stop
everything you're doing okay good oh my
God look at that face I mean [ __ ] up
yeah that's right there will be no ass
for you tonight boy oh God
grab that and don't [ __ ] up have you
seen that gift
so I almost suggest that would have been
embarrassing oh the little girl that
gets pulled down by a seal in the water
or an otter maybe it is [ __ ]
hilarious
google it google it right now
oh god he's coming back right away what
the [ __ ] dude chill chill bruh chill
chill chill
alright I'm telling you to chill chill
out relax max oh cool shoot some ball
outside a pool okay here we go let's go
for it when a couple of guys they were
up and no good start to make a commit
travel in my neighborhood I got in one
super little fight and my mother got
like wow
yes those are the original lyrics oh god
I think she's pissed now we got momentum
baby oh yeah let's keep going [ __ ]
killing it killing it man killing it for
a living
hell yeah man that was [ __ ] off Thank
You Felix
I mean Thank You myself see I have to
compliment myself cuz you bros I'm
[ __ ] doing
look at these gaming skills bro
someone's like you don't believe that I
play video games all day every day
they were deaths by the way and retype
it that way son that's why that's my
[ __ ] you can go suck a dick
without ugly face boy oh you nailed it
skills oh you thought I scales all you
are I'm dead I'm dead you know I get
these skills by respecting Armand oh
there's a hole there
what's Oh what
okay the epic troll let epic troll
everyone god and no toilet paper for you
son
that's right these as well okay now
maybe not maybe nine whatever I don't
care I don't care what that was [ __ ]
epic that was like a superhero
spider-man jump right there baby right
there baby
alright we're gonna have to pull this
briefcase oh god no I said pull it I
guess I can't do it huh
alright whatever I'm guessing we have to
transport an item from one side to
another while still managing the one
easy game is easy zero deaths puzzle
destroying run absolutely havoc okay
all right give me that little triangle
piece of [ __ ] I think I see it probably
one of these mother truckers no that's
an ugly ask where are you all right
toilet paper toilet paper doesn't get
way there it is okay and I have
something to tell you bros it's a little
embarrassing oh we saw before why didn't
you tell me then oh god I'm going to die
now not I'm fine okay aciss fallen
asleep is what I'm trying to say good
job you did it Wow amazing
other way okay perfect
can I don't want nothing to do with you
Ken oh wait sorry I did it wrong
boy genius genius
oh no and he's dancing like he dances
with his bro yeah I get it
oh that's right new compilation [ __ ] you
not today
no not today okay here we go
boy you're going right inside that
little ready to do B it keeps you didn't
realize triangle goes in triangle they
painted it red for us how nice thanks
everyone
ah we're gonna have to redo this
now let's redo this shut up again no one
likes you either you are legit can level
of dog if you were a kitchen household
item you'd be a can again okay god damn
it I [ __ ] that up tonight I forgot to
press the button midnight I'm off why
did no one tell Meg I might have to
strike off the genius on my title that
was pretty [ __ ] ha
even in it Davida babe I love me I love
you every time okay
ready you ready you ready boy you're
ready boy here we go man hey ho [ __ ]
say no that sounded weird okay here we
go yeah boy we did it we did it man easy
game is easy main doors Ivy [ __ ] them
why oh [ __ ] she's sitting in the chair
in shape
oh god don't panic
I don't panic I'm sure I'm dead that's
fine that's fine just swim
I just don't worry don't worry I'm
absolutely destroyed yeah hey it's me
I'm back so basically there's not that
much left I so I thought okay I might as
well just finishes in one episode
instead of dragging it out to - I know
I'm a nice person jesus [ __ ] christ
calm down
oh my god this [ __ ] is not messing
around is she but all right well I am a
dead man in now well it looks like you
don't have to do that [ __ ] well
can she mess with it oh my god you
[ __ ] go oh my lord god she's mean I
do not like her Shane oh oh how is it to
wash I'm like oh okay I turn on the
television
you think [ __ ] like television huh it
seemed like I would climb onto that lamp
doesn't it oh thank god that worked okay
another lever you all know the love God
ah you're such a prick
now why ah I meant to land on them
what's the plan here oh I think
I'm dead
get up get up get up now what the [ __ ]
are you doing get it up again oh oh
[ __ ] is coming up here now oh god what
do I do
there's the hole there stop it
oh I got fried like potato pie
I can [ __ ] pushing I thrive so many
times to push a go down your stupid TV
oh that's right you get fried [ __ ] you
gotta fry like pizza pie [ __ ]
[ __ ] yes I am the one health god
damn it
[ __ ] is dead that's why that's worth a
high five are you ready okay alright
[ __ ] I ruin it okay my flashlight still
works after all that that's great top
bottom on until you lie to us this is
pretty pie here I stole jacksepticeye's
brand now with these headphones the [ __ ]
are you doing something tells me this
[ __ ] is not dead you know when you kill
them you when you when you have
something annoying for a long time they
never die okay you want them to die and
then the guy and then they never done
alright it's Friday the 13th all over
again
why am i speaking like a pillow alright
long as matter it better be a sign that
says you're awesome at the top of this
oh oh I was the collecting guy [ __ ]
sake
maybe he maybe he told whispers you're
awesome dude I love your [ __ ] man
O'Shea we're locked in here with a
little girly no no aah
[Music]
we were the one that had to go what did
he do with it my mind is thinking some
pretty sick stuff right now disgusting
despicable I believe that was the little
nightmares dlc short but sweet as you
say I liked it very nice I don't think
it compared to the original one but I'll
take whatever we can get I thought it
was great anyway I love this cinematic
platforming ciphered genre I really hope
they make more of them
I hope this games as well so more people
will follow I wasn't sure if inside did
well or not I understand it's a it's not
maybe just about justifiable for a lot
of people to pay the amount when you get
a shorter amount of gameplay out of it
but I think it's cool that they make DLC
like this so you get a little bit extra
let me know what you thought of the DLC
any thoughts maybe something I missed
they would like to be enjoyed watching
and as always
sister Pfister